வேலை யாராவது இருக்காங்கள் அதில்
குருகித்துக் கொண்டிருக்கிறேன்
இந்தக்கு நம்முடைய குறிஞ்சுகள் அனைத்தையும் பேசும் வேலைகள் இருக்கிறார்கள், வெனேஸ் பேசும் வேலைகள் இருக்கிறார்கள்
நான் விட்டுவிட்டேன் அம்மா
ஆனா இன்று நாம் அந்த விட்டுவிட்டு ஆரம்பிக்கலாம் என்று
நாங்கள் இரண்டு விஷயங்கள் கேட்டிருந்தோம்
இந்த விட்டுவிட்டு ஆரம்பிக்கலாம் என்று தெரியும்
கர்மா என்றால் விஷயங்கள் கர்மா செய்யும் என்று கேட்டிருந்தோம்
கர்மா என்றால் விஷயங்கள் கர்மா செய்யும்
இது இரண்டு குஷ்ணங்கள் மட்டும் அதே கொஞ்சம் நாம் பேசவேண்டும்னால் அதிலிருந்து நிறைய குஷ்ணங்கள் வேண்டும் என்றால் ஞானாவும் சொன்னார் நாம் பேசவேண்டும்னால் அதிலிருந்து நிறைய குஷ்ணங்கள் வேண்டும்
அப்புறம் நாம் அந்த குஷ்ணங்கள் செய்து போய்க்கொண்டிருக்கலாம்
குஷ்ணங்கள் வேண்டும்னால் அதிலிருந்து பேசவேண்டும்னால் அதிலிருந்து போய்க்கொண்டிருக்கலாம்
மிக்ரோ வெளியில் நடக்கும் செயல்கள் மிக்ரோ வெளியில் நடக்கும் செயல்கள் மிக்ரோ வெளியில் நடக்கும் செயல்கள்